[Music]
tony is with us in atlanta hi johnny how
are you
hey i'm gary how are you dave better
than i deserve how can i help
okay so there's a lot of meat this but
let me just get right into it
so i am 48 years old i'm on
baby step number two i've only got
five thousand dollars until i'm debt
free and it's credit card debt
so i'm working on that good now
i am on social security death
benefit income and basically
on that income it says that i can only
make a certain amount
a year which i believe it's like 19 700
or something
um before they start you know taking
away from me from what i've made so it's
kind of been hard for me to get anything
other than a part-time job but i have
had them
now i will tell you that um
due to covid my doctor took me out
because i was high risk
but i did get released last month for
my uh sort of you know to get really to
go back to work here's the pickle i
meant
i've been apartment living for eight
years my daughter is 14
or will be 14 years old in november
and when she's 16 she has expressed to
me that she does want to have a
job so i do want to
help her and aid her in getting a car
for her
however i would also like to have a home
i'm kind of stuck i can't do both
because i just i'm not able to afford to
do those
but i want to know which one to do so
your husband passed away and you have a
social security death benefit from his
being deceased that's true how long ago
uh he passed in 2007. i'm sorry
okay um
i am not you so you're telling me that
on a death benefit from a deceased
spouse they stop
that if your income gets too high are
you sure that doesn't sound right
i bet i last not last year so what is
the death benefit how much do you get
i get 935 for my portion and i get 935
for her point
i'm 100 percent sure it does not affect
her portion
it does it does not affect her portion
it will affect my portion when she's
so what it's ten thousand dollars a year
girl go have a life screw the government
well and that's what you're trying to
figure out you're sitting around for ten
thousand dollars a year handcuffed when
you could go have a life
yeah well i i did that i actually went
out got a full time no you need like
you're 48 freaking years old there's
nothing wrong with you you need like
what's on
full-time gone get it go get it girl
career
go make you 60 80 100 000 and flip your
pinky towards washington as you do it
i did that actually a year and a half
ago and then i got stuck to the
government
by them taking away i think it was 130
each month who gives a crap about 130
dollars if you're making 80
well i'm not able to make 80 because i
am even even though i've
went to high school i am not um a high
oh i'm sorry even though i went to
college i am not a college graduate
so what so lots of non-college graduates
make 80.
i talked to one last week made 300
selling real estate
i'm trying to find that job that will
put me over
honey it don't take much this is a
squirrel bar this is a low bar it's 10
grand
squirrel can get over this bar it's low
it's way down there low like it's not
even knee high
it's ankle high yeah
let me tell you let me tell you okay
let's stop just a second all right
i'm going to tell you what i think i'm
hearing and you can correct me and i'll
be happy to be corrected but i think
when your husband passed away like for
most people
it was devastating yeah
and you and your daughter have clung
onto each other
and grieved and hurt from this
and mixed in with that you didn't think
you were valuable because you didn't get
a college degree which is not true by
the way that's a lie from the pit of
hell
and the second thing is you lost some of
your confidence
when he left yeah
and now you've set your value down at
ten thousand dollars and i'm sitting
here saying
honey your value's a lot higher than ten
thousand dollars
i believe in you like way more than you
believe in you and i've only talked to
you one minute
it's been hard i know that's what i'm
hearing i'm hearing some pain in there
am i missing
that no you're not missing it
so you were you were 42 years old and
your husband died right or 40 years old
yeah how did he pass away
he it was a combo they don't know what
it got him first it was either
um lung cancer or cirrhosis oh my gosh
yeah oh my god and that was another
situation yeah there's a situation that
goes with that for sure
yeah yeah so there's a lot of pain a lot
of pain around all of this
and it is a normal human behavior for
that pain
to leave a scar on our psyche
and i just want to tell you out loud as
somebody just listening to you i'm not
talking to a lady that's unintelligent
you're very articulate you made your
case in a very short period of time you
got on the radio which is a
nerve-wracking thing to do
and you pulled off this conversation not
everybody can do that not everybody can
get past kelly to get on the air
i mean you did all of this today and so
i think that um
i just and i'm not i'm not you know i'm
not blowing smoke i really do believe
you are worth
five to ten times more in the
marketplace than you
think you're worth
i do believe that myself and i think we
need to develop a career path
and track that might take you a year to
get on it might take a little time
but to start to believe and take some
steps in the right direction
towards something that gets your income
way up because this government idea of
ten thousand dollars hovering over your
head
it's not like they're offering you a
hundred thousand dollars they didn't
offer
you a good life they offered you below
poverty and you took it
yeah well here's the second option okay
what about going back to school
well you don't necessarily have to go
back to school if if that's what it
takes to go live your dream
we'll talk about that but that's not
necessarily the magic
pill yeah the magic pill might be
the magic pill might i mean because let
me just get i'm not suggesting you do
this but let me just give you an example
the example i mean
used a minute ago you do not have to
have a college degree to sell
residential real estate
and if you told me that was your dream
and i'm not suggesting it is but
that's an example of something where
going back to school is not necessary
now if you want to get a master's degree
in psychology because you want to do
grief counseling as a professional
counselor because you've been through
some stuff
then yeah you need to go back to school
for that so here's what we're gonna do
i'm gonna put you on hold and kelly's
gonna pick up we're going to plug you
into the ken
coleman stuff let me get your income up
to where this little ten thousand dollar
pittance the government is throwing you
and devaluing you with
is no longer holding you back